I really struggled earlier with how to
sort of present this story to you so
that it would transmit the true
absurdity that it represents so maybe
the best place to start is with some
basics like for example the federal
deficit has been skyrocketing under
Donald Trump the federal deficit is up
nearly a third 32% in the first 11
months of fiscal 2018 over fiscal 2017
up about two hundred and twenty-two
billion dollars this is according to the
nonpartisan Congressional Budget Office
why is the deficit up well the
Republican tax law is part of the
problem and increases in spending are
part of the problem if you reduce tax
revenues and you increase spending your
deficit is going to go up nothing
mathematically complicated about that
what is expected to happen next year and
the year after more of the same the same
Congressional Budget Office estimates
that we are going to have more deficit
growth in 2019 fiscal year 2019 and then
even more beyond that in fiscal year
2020
so first of all let me make very clear
this is not a conversation about whether
deficits matter and how much they matter
we've talked a lot in the last year and
a half to two years about modern
monetary theory and the growing reality
that a dollar of deficit is not always
the same for the economy the deficit
spending on stuff that stimulates the
economy is good right it's not or at
least it's not necessarily bad but on
the other hand growing the deficit to
give rich people tax cuts that they will
put mostly in bank accounts is not good
for the economy but that's not what I
want to talk about today right we've got
that part down we've talked about that
many times Donald Trump ran on reducing
the deficit and on paying down the
national debt the exact opposite is
what's actually happening but I think
even more importantly than that we got
these new deficit numbers the day after
we found out that when former Trump
economic adviser Gary cone went to trump
and said mister
whatever he calls a mr. president who
cares whatever name he had for him he
said Donald Donny boy the federal funds
rate is going to go up Donald Trump had
the bright idea of starting to print
more money in order to then make money
by holding US currency which he would
just print now you can debate whether
that's a good idea
but Trump and Republicans have run for
decades on economic theory that
supposedly claims that you can't do that
that that is inflationary and that it is
an absolute economic disaster to do that
what we have learned from this
experiment are a few different things
number one Trump and Republicans don't
care about the deficit I've been saying
this for a while it's a political
football the deficit matters when Barack
Obama is in office I'd say when Bill
Clinton's in office although he had a
surplus at the end of his presidency but
when george w bush is in office or
donald trump is in office who could
deficit who cares about the deficit
we're cutting taxes for the rich and for
big corporations deficit i don't even
know what you're talking about that's
what we learned number one even though
we already probably knew that number two
and this is not a new theme donald trump
has no idea how money works I'm not
talking about economics he obviously has
no idea how economics works he doesn't
seem to understand how money works and
then thirdly and this is the really sort
of damaging important stuff
Republicans will then use the fact that
these deficits exist because they gave
tax cuts to the rich to support more bad
policy by saying listen we've got
deficits we've got to cut Medicare and
we've got to cut Social Security
benefits even though they caused the
problem I jokingly what was that phrase
I've been using about the Trump
administration solutions that don't work
two problems that don't exist
this is solutions that don't work two
problems you caused and that's when it
starts to ruin people's lives in a real
way and again I know people are going to
write to me because every time I talk
about debt and deficit people write in
with two different
basically two different themes number
one people write in clearly
misunderstanding the difference between
debt and deficit I'm not going to review
that today we've already talked about
that before the other one is I get
emails from people saying David you
don't still think the deficit matters do
you and the answer is well the deficit
does matter but what modern monetary
theory is increasingly illuminating is
that a dollar of deficit is not always
created equal and what matters is why
did we get into that deficit dollar in
the first place was it to give a rich
person another dollar to stash away in
their bank accounts in a totally non
economically stimulative way or did that
dollar go to give someone health care
who now by virtue of being healthier is
going to work more and make more money
and the government gets more money
because they're earning income taxes or
collecting income taxes and that person
now has more money to go out and spend
it at local businesses that's what
matters okay so if you're gonna write in
and say David the deficit doesn't matter
at all
I've not seen evidence to suggest it
doesn't matter at all but what I am
increasingly convinced of is that what
matters is how did we get into that
deficit over the long term if you're not
following the david pakman show on
instagram you're missing a lot of really
great stuff including david pakman show
videos on IG TV we are on instagram at
david pakman show please follow us there
and make sure you're also following me
if you want to see behind the scenes
pictures from my trip and everything
that I've been doing over the last
couple of weeks follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman we will take a quick
break part two of my interview with
Andrew Seidel from the Freedom From
Religion Foundation next then more
stories and a lot of really great stuff
coming up today